accompagné s'informer malgré le flou à
deux mois de l'entrée en vigueur du bric
site les entreprises s'interrogent sur
le futur j'ai besoin de savoir où je
vais mettre les pieds comme l'angleterre
mais fournisseurs en angleterre n'en
savent pas plus que moi je viens prendre
un peu la température du côté de
l'administration française et connaître
mes obligations et devoirs
au coeur de cette réunion le scénario le
plus compliqué hendrix it sans accord le
royaume uni deviendrait un pays tiers
l'angleterre devient un pays sur lequel
il n'y a plus aucun n'accord donc on
repart sur une page blanche teint et que
nous n'avons aucun accord pour avoir des
accords équivalents à ceux que nous
avons avec certains prix vis des pays
privilégiés comme la norvège ou la
suisse où les états unis vont nous
demander au minimum dix ans de travail
pour arriver à mettre en place un
certain nombre d'accords il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises il inhale qui font du
commerce avec le royaume uni parce que
c'est un partenaire privilégié d'un
point de vue économique mais jusqu'à
présent elle ne faisait pas forcément de
grand export elle faisait de l'intra
communautaire c'est à dire qu'elle
n'était pas soumise aux règles de douane
dans les yvelines
elles sont plus d'une centaine notamment
des petits entreprises à être concernés
par ces échanges intracommunautaires si
aucun accord n'est trouvé les droits de
douane seront rétablis ces entreprises
elles vont devoir apprendre un métier
vous faire faire cette prestation par un
professionnel de la douane et donc elles
doivent c'est celle ci qui sont le plus
impacté par le break site puisque celles
qui font déjà de l'import et l'export
en réalité ça sera un peu plus dans leur
portefeuille export ou encore le coeur
de cible des douanes les entreprises
exportant télé pme avec un mot clé
l'anticipation il reste deux mois avant
la mise en place du bric site